[Music]
the absence of moscow the russian team
is preparing for the international
aviation and space salon this is a major
airshow that's going to take place at
the end of august and there's going to
be air tech and pilots from countries
all over the globe no doubt the pilots
are going to be showing off their best
stunts for this event and we were lucky
enough to get invited onto a plane to
join one of those pilots so I hope
you're not afraid of heights
[Music]
no you can play okay let's get a bigot
it's the Safeway right
down
okay yes the back you know at school
[Music]
Wow
when you're 40 build at them okay
[Music]
after we returned in one piece our pilot
Constantine told us all about the
international aviation and space salon I
have been training for more than 10
years and I've been in the pilot team
for four years
the airshow include the max Coppa
featuring aerobatic performances and the
standard maneuvers and championships
rolls and loops etc the international
tournament features competitors from
many European countries and non-european
countries including the US the airshow
is not a contest the contest happens at
the championship with the aerobatic and
other events so what the airshow each
group shows its skills and the
spectators decide for themselves what
they like of course we will show what we
do best and what's new
you